I'm probably not going to introduce
these people because I think they'd
probably do a better job introducing
themselves well I'm just going to give
an introduction and that'll let
everybody introduce themselves because
they could probably tell you all the
awesome stuff they're doing better than
I can
I want to thank Dennis for inviting me
out here he he contacted me and he told
me that he thought you know the stuff I
was working on was really cool is really
similar to the stuff that happened with
the homebrew Computer Club except with
biology so I'm one of those people who
kind of calls myself a bio hacker now it
comes from the hacker term not you know
the black hat and a Farias type of
hacker but more the original usage of
the word where somebody's doing
something clever and new and kind of
ingenious with the technology and bio
hacking is doing something clever and
new and cool with with biology what
happened was I was once like all of you
[Laughter]
like I hope not yeah so I was in
academia I did my PhD in biochemistry
and biophysics and as I was going
through academia and also NASA I worked
for two years at NASA doing genetic
engineering and synthetic biology the
one thing I saw was that like all the
cool things that we wanted to be work I
mean people who do computer science and
electrical engineering or you already
get to work on the cool thing so right
you're already making robots
self-driving cars artificial
intelligences and things like that
really awesome that's what everybody
wants in biology
what we want is like you know dragons we
want humans with prehensile tails and
stuff like that and instead I spent my
PhD studying the biophysical mechanisms
of light activation in the Avena sativa
light oxygen voltage protein exactly
that's not to say what is that what
happened and so it kind of inspired me
and I started thinking well there's all
these things that people want to do but
you can't get the grants to do it or
it's too fringe right you can imagine
somebody saying I want to make a dragon
and people just be like you're
ridiculous you're crazy get out of here
but we're starting to get to the place
with this biological technology or we
can edit genomes really easy of all
types of organisms and we can start
making things with that right it's
really impressive and awesome what's
going on right now and so I started to
get in well how can I take this to like
a hobbyist level right you got these big
labs where you're doing these
experiments kind of like the days when
you know the only people had computers
were labs and universities and big
companies and then it started move
slowly away from that you started to get
the hobbyist involved and that's what's
happening now you know and I started
building a lab in my apartment and then
other people you know I wasn't the one
who initiated this but then a lot of
other people are building labs and their
apartments and is starting to grow and
grow and grow people are engineering
organisms in their apartments for little
or no money you know people are using
equipment that was once thousands and
hundreds of thousands of dollars now
getting it used or building it
themselves for hundreds of dollars right
and it's this change of the digital
right the digital is always going to be
there and it's computers allowed us
crazy access to this digital world we
can do stuff but now the biological
right you can take a seed and from that
seed you can grow a massive tree all
right and it gets its carbon from carbon
dioxide and elements from the soil right
like that tree grew from carbon dioxide
in the soil that kind of blows my mind
so how can we use that though how can we
use that right and you know even when I
was in synthetic biology and academia
but especially now you know being in the
Bay Area and Silicon Valley people like
to make these claims like cells our
computers and DNA is a programming
language right but they're not right
people have tried there there's there's
been papers published where people are
like let's make and and or gates and
cells and then like - ow
later they're able to do one single
computation right you're like what is
that gonna compete with hey come on in
programming DNA no matter how hard
people try to make DNA a programming
language it's not an exact thing right
it's a it's a dynamic system there's so
many different things going on you know
DNA does make proteins but there's all
these other things that affect it right
the post translational modification of
these proteins miss isolation of these
proteins like the temperature the
thermodynamics of the system that's
involved the sodium all these different
things in there that allow proteins to
fold and interact with other things and
it's like why are we trying to make it a
programming language and why are we not
just seeing the things it's good for and
learning how to access that right
organisms growing things building things
and things like that anyway it's my
little rant about what the talk is gonna
be about today you heard a little bit
about me so why don't you all introduce
yourselves and let us know a little bit
about you sure I'll start hey thanks
everybody for having us I'm Moe Islam
I'm a venture capitalist at dfj we have
an early stage and growth stage tech
fund and life sciences fund investing in
kind of the intersection of information
technology and and biotechnology so
investors in companies like synthetic
synthetic genomics human longevity Inc
which the name is kind of in there of
what they're trying to do but then also
companies like Adam wise and zymogen
that are doing everything from machine
learning applied to drug discovery to
optimizing microbes to produce things
like flavors fragrances things like that
so really interested in in how we can
use technology to kind of unlock the
power of biology you know I think
similar to design I think that the
analogy that a lot of people have been
using especially a lot of tech investors
are guilty of this we're starting to put
money into these life science companies
without really understanding what we're
doing but you know a lot of that is
happening right now in the valley and I
like to I like to think we're smarter
about that but you know we've you know
every every VC has it
as it's a bad portfolio we only get one
out of ten so you just got to get one
that one but you know you know with the
kind of the advent of the cost of
sequencing coming down you know faster
than even you know Moore's Law would
predict in terms of you know
computational power you know - this
multimodal generation of data that we
have now with DNA RNA where we can do
things like you know map genomic data to
phenotypic data understand disease
states it's kind of phenomenal from my
perspective as an investor just what
we're seeing in the market now with all
of these companies getting started and a
lot of capital flowing into these
companies and so including some that
we're gonna hear about today some of
these guys are actually starting
companies I'm just I'm just the investor
but really excited about what we're
seeing the market you know I don't think
cells have to be you know computers I
don't think DNA has to be a programming
language but you know I think we can
still leverage those and use technology
advances in computation and in hardware
with costs coming down and kind of
leverage the power of biology so that's
that's what I'm really excited back yeah
so my name is hungry enemy to get sort
of the embarrassing thing thing out of
the way I am a science fiction author
and you may know me as the author of
books like the quantum thief but I do
you have an academic background as a
theoretical physicist I did my PhD in
string theory which is probably probably
even worse started the company working
on data science and AI but then really
got very excited about biology and
actually what really drew me into
biology or the sort of paper I read that
really sort of made me realize that
something crazy was happening was a
paper about DNA logic gates not because
not because it was sort of impressive
computationally but the fact that we
could engineer a very artificial system
we actually had the ability to put it
into a living cell and do something and
yes noisy rubbish sort of sort of
nothing like our silicon but still what
could it actually what could a system
like that do if you actually put in
to the body and so I sort of started
thinking about that that that space and
and I think there is this kind of
long-running fascination that people
coming from mathematics and physics have
with with biology going back to people
like Alan Turing and genre Neiman Hugh
sort of bow both worked on both things
and I think one of the first programs
that the the Joanie act the sort of
first programmable computer that Von
Neumanns team built at Princeton ran was
actually an artificial life simulation
back in the 50s so this is sort of a
long long association but I'm sort of
definitely excited about this space
because I believe that we do now have
this amazing stack of tools that allows
even individual hobbyists sort of do
self experiments and very very cool
experiments and and there's so much
unknown about biology that that even a
single individual or a small team can
make astonishing discoveries that have
tremendous impact on human health so I'm
a co-founder of a startup called helix
nanotechnologies and we're sort of an
early stage startup trying to work on
new ways to actually get synthetic DNA
that could do some of these exciting
things into into human cells so so yeah
I'm very happy to be here and tell you
about our journey with these guys you
know I think the weirdest but I you know
I think I was invited because what I saw
happening about 25 or 30 years ago and
when I see happen now
so 25 years ago this month we launched
Wired magazine my partner Luis Rosado
and I had come from Amsterdam where we
were watching what was happening as all
these different data types were getting
digitized and what people were then
going to be doing with those
we were watching the horse first text
and then all the interesting things
around how we understand text and so
that listen to sort of machine
translation and sorts of neural networks
and linguistic programming all that
local stuff and then of course we were
with a magazine called electric word and
then we thought you know this is going
to change but it's gonna change the way
we learn we are entertained the way we
store things gonna change business is
going to change politics and change our
culture it's been changed everything
so we coin a phrase digital revolution
we moved to San Francisco to launch wire
literally 25 years ago this month which
seems like a very long time ago one of
our first employees was kevin kelly who
wrote a book in 1994 actually took
sabbatical from Whole Earth Catalog to
publish this book and then he took a
sabbatical from his book helped us
launch wire and his what was called out
of control and the subtitle on the
original issue was fast forwarded to a
neo biological civilization the stuff he
was writing about then I mean first of
all the book was like you know became a
vital in the collapse of hierarchical
systems IT person and how were they with
wheels and how quickly they were going
to but what was really interesting was
the stuff he was talking about was
biological and it was so out there 25
years ago and about three or four years
ago I picked up the book again
my post as president of choc chocolate
which had this fabulous chocolate
factory open Embarcadero in San
Francisco and dealing with my three
octogenarian parents so I started
thinking about mental illness which they
were suffering from Alzheimer's was kind
of a profound and shocking okay to
realize and it came at a time when my
hormones were changing no no I'm not
this static thing anymore
I'm kind of this amorphous thing and I'm
shifting what I eat and the bacteria
that I'm surrounded by the hormones that
I'm producing or ingesting and so I
began to go to medical conferences and
read books and all of a sudden I thought
these are the smartest people in the
world you know these PhDs
you know who are deep deep deep into
neuroscience which is that it's sort of
microbiology whatever it may be and we
expect them to be hackers now and and so
I just began to realize that not only is
it changing the way I think about my
body of my longevity and my family but
it's have you think about fertility how
do you think about exercise how do you
think about what you eat this was all
happening that Silicon Valley was gonna
throw stupid amounts of money and a
whole new profusion of innovation that
could take us into places that people
could hardly imagine and no one was
imagining it and I realized as a former
publisher I've been out of many business
for a very long time and I began to
realize there was actually no place to
go
where you could get all that information
and get that
context and get that perspective other
than science fiction and you know
there's like the science jerk for
science but there's some science
journals which are very vertical which
is what would happen when I would go to
these conferences you know there'd be
these people who are so demoness but
everything that came out of my mouth was
a complete shocker to them because they
were not able to piece the pieces
together and see how it all would play
out there were and our business
publications and it's all about you know
who's investing in what and what
categories are hot but again there's no
context around that you know or there's
the general media which is you know
really generated by the stuff that
people like desire to but still lacking
context and lacking you know sort of
grounding in the science of technology
so I decided to go back to media and
I've watched this publication with and
it's called neo life and that's using
dot life as a domain and so we are
putting together stories that cross over
all these disciplines and that try and
paint a picture of where we're headed
and that picture very much like back in
the wire days is about Adi evolution of
power and information from you know
hospitals and pharmaceutical companies
and doctors into the hands of patients
and hackers and hobbyists it's about you
know our cultural response to that what
are the science fiction writers you know
writing about what our television
programs and movies about what are the
our visions of the future I mean we are
in live right now at a time when we can
edit the humans online and so we will
change our species faster in the next
five years than they just probably
changed in the last so the rate of
acceleration of evolution
but it's also this specific moment in
time when we're trying to figure out
what CRISPR means when we can use it
when we can't and then what happens when
you put regulations in place that
everyone in China is ignoring anyway and
so there's just all these big technical
questions scientific questions
regulatory questions cultural issues and
I just wanted to be I think you said
some really interesting things and
that's one thing maybe I'm interested in
maybe you know I didn't plan on doing
this at all but I think it would be a
brilliant question because you know some
of you though you don't look like it
lived through the time when computers
went from the size of a room to like a
personal computer and now with biology
stuff we see a lot of debates about like
the ethics of everything right it's like
is it ethical to do this is it ethical
to do that and that seems like a lot of
what's going on and one question this is
just personal I'm sorry everybody this
is just personal like what was going on
then we're people arguing about this
stuff with computers where people like
is it ethical to give people personal
computers there's an ethical to like use
computers just do this stuff and get it
over network to work which I think these
now the pros with biology is very hard
to get
sort of parallel with the history of
computers so I recently read a great
book called called what the Dormouse
said by by John Markoff so I have no
first-hand experience of any any of that
these things but what was really
fascinating about the sorts of story of
Silicon Valley is how closely the
development of technology is was in
meshed with sort of social and cultural
and ideological issues how all the same
counterculture people doing LSD
experiments being part of the sort of
anti-war movement etc were also the
people at that sort of SSRI and Doug
Engelbart's labs or developing windowed
interfaces and the first Mouse and and
and all that and and I forget now the
sort of name was the founder of the
homebrew Computer Club who got his
initial grant from Stewart Brand he was
a very active sort of member of the sort
of anti-war movement who wanted to - who
actually wanted a computer - to organize
his social network of like-minded people
instead of using using sort of file
cards and things like that so so that
sort of computer as a tool or
decentralized organization or sort of a
tool for bringing people together I was
kind of baked in from the start and I
think some of that nito's still still
survives and it's actually not
completely clear to me and maybe it's
hard to see it because it's happening
right now what's the sort of ideological
and political sentiments behind by
hacking are I mean what sort of well are
there similar trends so sort of pushing
us to do crazy things with cells in DNA
we know there was that famous debate
between Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs
over whether or not you should be able
to violently split down the middle
everybody's very excited that the people
in charge sort of hospitals and doctors
and they're excited about the things
that they want to do but there's this
other thing that's just bursting at the
seams it's just exploding of people who
want this what I'm interested in right
now and maybe y'all could something we
could talk about it's like what's going
on right now right for me it's the whole
biohacker thing you know that that like
envelops my life hobbyists who are
starting to get this technology and use
it right and they're just doing whatever
they want with it you know screw
regulations and ethics and everything
like that that kind of develops my own
but you are are from you know completely
different points of view Jane you tend
to see everything Han oh right you
running a business and mo you're seeing
all the businesses going up so what like
what's going on now besides you know
biohacking yeah I mean you know in terms
of gene-editing there's there's actually
you know I think a lot of people in the
audience know about CRISPR and kind of
the revolutionary technology it may end
up becoming you know it's still pretty
early but your desire we're just talking
about this before the panel ton of
public companies now that are working on
getting to human trials now like in
China you know you don't have that sort
of regulatory barrier here that sort of
you know I would argue the ethical
considerations when it comes to gene
editing are even greater than you know
programming assembly or you know hacking
into a Mac or whatever maybe just
because you're dealing with the human
body and there's this sort of notion of
playing God well you're in there you're
you're in it you know what's the bigger
fear ai or hacking and maybe using AI to
do the bio hacking can't even do our own
[Laughter]
no you know it's I think I disagree with
Elon on this because you know I think
he's made some statements about you know
how worried he is about the
proliferation of a I you know I you know
I think
that could happen theoretically in the
future where you know if somehow AIS are
able to reproduce in the wild and you
know we can't just pull the plug or
splash some water on them this is it's a
very crude analogy but yeah I think with
with biohacking in general there's
there's just this fear among especially
you know synthetic biology that the term
almost had a very negative connotation
just looking back in the last ten years
even before you know CRISPR existed and
you know I think there's sort of this
public education piece that has to be
part of it to educate people the
benefits of using these as therapies
right if you can if you can correct you
know a single gene mutation for somebody
who has a sickle cell anemia that could
change their life right and if you have
a cure that would be enormous and so
there's there's a lot of work going into
this now companies academics you know
China it argues a little ahead just
because they don't have the regulatory
barrier but there are I think real
therapies that we're gonna see developed
over the next two five to ten years that
are going to save people's lives
because of things like gene I think I
got another quest the Morris worm did
that set things back or no
where people just like ya know
so can you beat the Morris worm Robert
Morris he wrote this one that crashed a
bunch of went and spread and crash bunch
of beauties use like finger and all this
other stuff it didn't set like computers
back or anything like people weren't
more scared of computer systems or
anything that's for sure cuz I mean I
think about you know boy you're saying I
think about like you know it's true that
a lot of these things can't spread in a
digital world and biohackers it can
spread if something bad happens back I
don't know oh no but what do you see how
new going on well I mean where the sort
of basic startup founder half and then
you know so just even even if we sort of
restrict ourselves to mainstream biotech
it is an extraordinary time I mean we
just had literally this year
first approved FDA approved gene therapy
I'm sort of spark therapeutics is viral
viral jet therapy for four sort of a
rare III condition and then then we have
also no more disease if you know what I
found crazy about that right
like the luck sterno which costs what I
think or something like that yeah you
can go and you could order the vai have
a custom order a virus that you know
replaces I forget it's some retinol you
know gene in the eye for like three
thousand dollars if you just went to a
company and knew the gene pretty
interest I mean it might be a little a
little bit more expensive for a far sort
of clinical grade so it is it is true
that so these these new therapies do
come with enormous price tags I mean
that's that's why they are sort of
targeting these very rare debilitating
diseases or cancer but but they are
getting FDA approval and these are sort
of very extreme therapies where where
you infect the patient with this this
virus that deliver its genetic payload
into the into the eye or or in case of
cambria you actually take the patient's
t-cells out you genetically engineer
them and then you put them back into to
go after so that so the blood cancer
I mean these are these are quite extreme
biohacking feats I mean I mean there's a
sort of and FDA is now willing to to
sort of go with these so I think we will
see a lot more coming through through
that that pipeline and then the question
becomes can we afford to pay for them
what is actually the model for
regulating some of them more even more
innovative therapies where you can take
an individual patients tumor and
sequence it and tailor a therapy for
that particular patient how do you know
you sort of take that through through
clinical trials and that's like an
interesting interesting relation to like
software and copyright because you know
when software came out and people
couldn't afford it or they didn't want
to afford it right they either broke the
copyright copied and shared it with
their friends or something like that you
think a similar thing will happen with
biologics like people be able to
reverse-engineer them and make them for
really inexpensively
yes quite possibly I mean you think the
problem we
so I think that's actually not to sort
of blow the helix in a trumpet but I
think you asks so right now we have to
make biologics in these very big
production facilities with tens of
thousands of litres of Chinese hamster
ovarian cells genetically engineered to
produce your sort of cancer drug or or
or or sort of enzyme replacement or
whatever it is that then sort of get
harvested and then purified but what if
you could get sort of hundred dollars
ten dollars worth of DNA inject that
into your own body and have your body
produced the biologic now right now we
can't do that because because there are
sort of limitations to the efficiency of
how much DNA you can get into the cells
and that's basically what we're working
on but yeah I think things could get
really crazy I mean we could see you
Cesar $50,000 money yeah right twelve
months just like you know digital
therapeutics right so we've got the
first digital pill and we got the first
digital approval from the FDA for unlike
therapeutics for mental illness and
addiction right so those there's this
vast array so lets me paint a picture so
the digital pill is something that you
swallow and it goes into your stomach
and the amount of stomach acid that it
register there's I forget the details of
it but it's or therapeutic don't care if
it's prettiest prettiest yes but they
sold it to or there's a company that's
using its commercialized it's pretty
assist technology and it picks up
stomach acid and that's how it knows
what to release yeah the idea is to
track it and make sure that you're
actually taking the pill
yeah yeah so yes there is that sort of
whole whole other side of how does how
to sort of are generally information
technology and also sort of generally
better understanding for biology being
into like they're like the microbiome so
connection between the nervous system
and inflammatory response how does that
sort of enable new kinds of therapeutic
services a company called link who sort
of started out as a so an electro
therapeutic for for or actually actually
they saw it as cognitive enhancement
they sort of try to try to have sort of
direct liver and brain stimulation to
enhance performance and what some of
their patients some of those test
subjects ended up finding was that there
sorry ACS got better and now they're
sort of certain active so psoriasis
sorry my my fitness comes through
[Laughter]
another interesting example of that that
sort of there's new biological insights
that all them to understand what's
actually happening and then they have
this new sort of fad chief technology
the liberating platform that looks very
different from your traditional drug or
injection so but we're into the scary
stuff I mean I think sort of as our
powers grow I mean one one interesting
example or sci-fi had out of getting in
there getting there I mean the scary
corollary of CRISPR is sort of the
actually the ability to manipulate
entire ecosystems through through things
like teen droids so dream drawing is
essentially an application of CRISPR
another genome editing tool where you
put a foreign gene into a population and
then the system ensures that every
descendents of every organism
gets gets that gene so it sort of
spreads through the population glowing
with wildfire and people are applying to
these things like actually sort of
making malaria spreading mosquitoes
infertile and things like that and they
are already feels trials so so I think
that sort of scary thing about biology
is that we can never sort of fully
control it like we have to set up these
elaborate frameworks in the clinical
context to try to control it I think
that's one reason why in in sci-fi
biology has always been consigned
complex instance of biology sci-fi is
Frankenstein yes that's right that's
right and it's actually it's actually a
remarkable book I mean one of my
favorite quick digressions into that
it's not that actually the
Frankenstein's monster is quite a
wonderful creature it's it's it's a it's
a super human being I mean it's it's
sort of smarter and stronger and so on
it's it's ugly but but sort of it says
essentially superhuman what sort of
drives it into this destructive behavior
is not some inherent evil but the fact
that but overfloor but but sort of the
fact that Victor Frankenstein rejects it
he sort of abhors his own creation and
refuses to take responsibility and
that's what sort of drives the monster
to do to do harm and I think that's a
very good lesson which most people kind
of tend to miss in when looking at the
movie or media versions but anyway I
mean I think we do have a lot to do and
hopefully people like Jane and Ken can
also sort of contribute to that through
through your your your channels to
actually kind of rebrand biology and
create better narratives there's an
eatery branding game is really weird
right because I see people who like
support human genetic engineering but
are against like food genetic
modification you're like I know
we produced you know meatless meat
animal free meat
you know wouldn't that be better look
how much water he would say look how
much gas we can be releasing to the
atmosphere look how much land compute
return to natural state or whatever it's
like these are market I mean we're we're
an investor in that this meets it's a
company that is actually isolating stem
cells from cattle from from ducks from
chickens would have these multi-modal in
terms of animals and they're actually
growing meat in a petri dish and they
have a consumer product that they're
working on now and they've actually done
trials with consumers where they've
given them real meat and the Memphis
meats which is real meat it's not it's
not you know it's literally from animal
cells and people love it
people love it so I think getting the
marketing right is gonna be vastly
important but once you you know once you
abstract away some of that the
underlying biology the petri dish what
have you you know ultimately people want
a great product regardless of its
technology or biotechnology and that's
where they've seen some success but it's
it's super important and getting the
story right is gonna be really important
to porch I think hopefully that's where
regulation comes in I mean regulation is
good and bad right that's what they're
gonna I'm predicting right now 20 50
election russians hacked the president
[Laughter]
we've been talking a lot about just you
know therapeutics and writing DNA but
just even reading DNA just the
innovations that have happened there I
mean the cost of sequence you know it's
three billion dollars to sequence a
human genome now companies can do whole
genome sequence for less than a thousand
and that continues to go down these are
anybody's interested you know your data
geeks the whole genome sequencing so yes
what's that well you have to find a
physician or a genetic counselor that
can help you you know put stuff into
context and they will give it to you if
you just want to play around so right
now it's really the interesting thing
about you know all this data that's been
collected so they've sequence thousands
of genomes of thousands yeah tons of
organisms and they've stored all this
data online so there's online
repositories of this a lot of studies
that have been done trying to associate
different genes with different diseases
or different mutations and different
genes for different diseases so there
there are actually websites out there
that are free to use where you can
upload you know sequences that you get
and they'll analyze it for you and give
you predictions based on data out there
so that that's stuff that you could
possibly do so I actually had my full
genome sequence through Illumina has
this event that they'll do they'll
sequence your genome pair you up with a
physician and you actually get a
clinical report that then he walks me
through and I actually had something
that was a clinically pathogenic so mc4r
is the gene that I have a mutation in
and it predisposes me to obesity so I
guess I have some you know fatties in my
family what he said but you know in
terms of a lifestyle change now I know
that you know I have to be careful about
what I eat how I exercise because you
know I'm genetically predisposed to
obesity so I have to think about that
and I think that information is super
powerful going forward and it causes me
to make lifestyle changes because I know
that hey you know there's there's
something that I have to you know
compete against when it comes to nature
but I can do that just you know it's not
DNA in itself right you can
make changes in your lifestyle to to
kind of account for those sort of things
and that that's why I was super useful
for me Craig Venters company and Craig
is the first person to sequence this
personal genome and until this month
actually for $25,000 you can go and get
this full body scan oh all right right
get your whole genome sequence do you
get all this other metabolic information
they would just give you a like ultra
leading-edge executive you know yeah
workout
they've just lowered the price to five
thousand dollars and so you get you know
the whole genome sequencing with which
these guys are they're four thousand
plus you get a whole bunch of additional
information that can spotted they're
finding up to thirty to forty for some
of the people who come in have some kind
of clinically relevant find it so they
may find out tumour five percent of the
people find tumors yeah they're finding
a lot of precancerous cells that could
become cancerous cells at like stage
zero you know Craig is convinced the
naysayers will tell you which is the
cancer that wouldn't actually you may
have them session but you know unless
you but this is the power of data no I
find out you have to bracket one gene
other in your grandmother had breast
cancer you know are you going to have a
prophylactic mastectomy I mean these are
the decisions people are making the
Casilla these things well this is how a
23andme was shut down because they did
not want to give this information to
people without the benefit of genetic
counsel you know but this is the same
thing the FDA said about at-home
pregnancy
tests you know that women would be
throwing themselves on bridges no I find
that really interesting about the whole
biology and bio hacking is that
computers allowed us to change our world
and have access to all these things that
affect us like digitally like you know
we can communicate with people we can
you know take care of our finances and
bank account and put put you know media
and everything out there for everybody
to see
but we can't affect us us right
it doesn't like I can't use no no I
understand I understand that but I mean
like now what I'm seeing with this whole
you know people getting into biology and
medicine like you're talking about what
happens if instead of five thousand
dollars I could walk down the street go
to a free clinic really test myself or
run it for free and you could check
yourself all the time how would that
change the things we do what happens if
I had I could write my own prescriptions
for myself for non like harmful
medications right how would that change
it requires a lot more prescriptions for
medicines that are available
over-the-counter countries yeah they do
that's it the big thing that's actually
going on right now because it's really
interesting right so in order to do
experiments on humans you have to go
through a huge process with the FDA
right usually have committees and for a
good thing right
usually you're trying to create a drug
or medication that treats the most
amount of people with harming the least
amount of
people right so and also make your
company money so you want it to be
really well tested well the problem with
that is that you can't test more things
that are more breakthrough or just
starting to come about or things that
are a little bit more risky but if you
test something on yourself it's okay
because the FDA needs kind of like a
plaintiff in order to like do something
and you're probably not gonna press
charges against yourself you hurt
yourself right so yeah no I mean it's
happening more and more now people are
trying to engineer themselves there have
been a number of cases in the past you
know six months where people are you
know engineering some DNA and inject
himself with it putting it in their
cells and seeing what happens a number
of cases where people are doing this and
it's only happening more and more I know
how many of those went sour none so far
yeah well I mean pretty lucky well so I
grew up you know you can't well here's
the interesting thing is that we don't
know enough to hurt ourselves too much
[Laughter]
yeah it's like you know if you're trying
to do something where you're affecting
some metabolic thing it can get a lot
more complicated but a lot of people are
interested in in pretty basic stuff
changing something that's you know like
the color of your skin or something or
like the amount of muscle you have or
something that's like really a lot
harder for it to go wrong but I imagine
something bad is going to happen for
sure and that's interesting thing like
how will it affect things will it be
more regulation less you know from other
things that have gone bad in computers
it seems like I don't know don't see
will we be able to attribute it to the
action they took yeah
not easy yeah I think we've had 20 years
ago 17 years ago at least we've had some
stage 4 cancer care yeah there was
something I never saw the light of day
because not because of FDA regulation or
anything like that just because the
pharmaceutical market doesn't support it
totally no I mean in the early days of
gene therapy they cured of leukemia a
lot I think there were there were like
10 patients or something in a trial that
they cured one ended up getting I forget
what it was maybe cancer but then they
did radiation and they cured that person
one person ended up dying but yeah this
technology has been around since the 80s
or 90s to me I think it's accessibility
I don't know when I see like computer so
I grew up you know in in the 90s kind of
like computer hacker BBS internet was
starting to go around accessibility is
what kind of made it for me right the
accessibility of knowledge about how to
program you know I read rfcs and other
stuff and open-source software and stuff
like that came from it I wrote code and
put it out there but right now it seems
like this stuff only ran on vaccin and
Sun workstations and the majority people
with pcs never would have seen a thing
we didn't get hits
we only con why were we late for macs
and a small number sighs we
SGI machines and craze and the thing is
most people don't even to this day don't
know how to program for crate and the no
seriously the reason is the fact that
most people don't realize that not all
computers you know an audition on one
computer is not the same thing as an
addition of another people don't even
realize word sizes and character sets
you know different stuff like that
now as DNA goes pretty much all living
things go with DNA I mean yet display
the case second Genesis as Chris McKay
would say for something using other than
you know there's scifi writers let me
tell you yeah my my favorite episode of
the original Star Trek was the episode
with the Horta which it was silicon
basis but we do now have far less our
potential diversity most people from
having more serious things and I mean
you know what most people don't realize
is the people who really do develop
weapons in the way of software you're
not being able to because they're
they're professionals and they're not
like script kiddies like items talk
about no there's actually professors
been a professional society for several
decades of electronic worker people and
they number thirty thousand members had
a meeting here at Stanford wants them
you know the big the unmanned aerial
vehicles autonomous cars and it turns
out six thousand members live in the Bay
Area and most people have never heard of
these now you have to tell north
computer Denny like why aren't you a
number of the Association of old crows
they go what yeah well that just creates
a OC organism to know they have the
professional means there's thousands of
these people who do it professionally
and they do it to both offensively and
defensively people
you know keep talking about biology
because though they're not thinking
about those guys aren't thinking about
biology where they're sequencing it
faster and cheaper than most companies
something I would say as well they
consider this a threat to US national
interests I can't talk too much against
[Music]
organisms I was talking about actually
have sort of DNA watermarks effectively
embedded in in the genome that can be
then later sequenced if somebody tries
to create strain from facilities also
people are these trying to develop it
some ways controlling controlling that
but then how do you how do you actually
fight back some of these deals you're
somebody all during the Coke routine of
influenza and Oprah makes the test tube
you know I mean ask you to sort of dress
the room and they are of course great
risks in parallel to this is what I
think about a little bit is that like
all right in modern times what's the
work so evolution has had a fair amount
of time to evolve things to harm humans
what's the worst thing you could think
of in modern time suppose Spanish flu in
1918 right like what's the worst I mean
cancer probably but it's caused by a
large number of things but like virus
bacteria we have modern sanitation it's
really hard to spread these things right
like smallpox brilliant
so larry was you know part of the effort
that eradicated the smallpox vaccine and
yet you know we are now people are
synthetically engineering you know
horsebox in labs to see if they can use
that for research purposes to create
other vaccines but yeah i easy is it to
spread right and like how would it
spread and play horse period win things
now how long does it take to kill half
the population when things are moving at
500 miles an hour and how long does it
take to grow those vaccines right and
then we have synthetic thumb seeds but
synthetic biology hasn't scaled yet you
know there's the manufacturing well I
was the point I was trying to make is
that I think it's again one of those
things where it's like we we don't know
enough to create something that would be
harmful enough like obviously if I
wanted to hurt somebody right now Oh
accident is even harder because
biological systems are so complex so
it's like I want to create some toxin
also the law of unexpected consequences
is very powerful at the bleeding edge of
and thanks to Carrie Fisher dyeing is
going to be today number first
it's they think people will get there
fast hackers will get their videos it's
actually writers perspective I mean we
can sort of go go back to that sort of
bio bio for corporate horror scenarios
but so I am I am writing a new novel
piece featuring so near future by
hacking and one of the sort of days I'm
really interested in is future by a
crime not involving sort of ending the
world or through a disease that kills us
all but something akin to what you were
you were describing so so this malicious
but sort of non will destroying slightly
disturbing typified by packing or by a
crime that sort of inconvenience us and
perhaps these glasses husband doesn't
doesn't exist so so so i guess this sort
of thing thing I'm thinking about is you
know unleashing some sort of fungal
species that spreads into into buildings
and causes a bad smell so sort of or
sort of you were sort of referring to
how can the u.s. president biological
rent somewhere where where you sort of
end up having to take a drug that home
didn't sort of biohacker can provide or
you get sort of annoying annoying holy
things
we're simply creating something like
that we're in history just kind of show
certainly with computers that the street
finds its own uses for things like weird
weird things will happen but the fake my
favourites bits of news recently was
Botox injections are now forbidden in
kennel Beauty contexts to modify kennel
appearance with Botox so the future will
be weirder and more more human and more
disturbing on some level than we can
possibly imagine I mean all sort of
biocera tears right side of things I
mean it is harder probably to engineer
pathogens that you'd you would sort of
instantly think that doesn't mean it's
it's not possible and we might see all
breaks with bioweapons in the future but
I guess there are sort of only
comforting hope there is that our
cultivators will also continue to get
better but better you were sort of
commenting on on vaccines I mean Norco
does have a big program running sort of
have to protect where the idea is that
you can just sequence the new virus into
the yield using a portable DNA sequencer
sent the DNA DNA code to to a remote lab
engineer very opposed to anybody against
which you can then put into synthetic
DNA and cheaply in Puerto Rico
running away no that's that's true but I
mean and I guess we'll have to tackle
tackle at all those levels but here
we've sort of been mostly focusing on on
technology and but you're you're
absolutely right I mean with any finding
finding a solution to any problem it's
it's the human element political element
social elements economic element that
also also comes into play and I guess
it's very hard to foresee how how the
sort of widespread availability of
various sparking tools will play with
those how big a factory does it take you
can so DARPA has designed these units
that do fit in basically shipping
containers so the so you need Soviet
cells and stuff to grow or or or the
sort of purely chemical methods where
where you basically need some enzymes
and a sort of a water fats that's gonna
be heated and cooled so about the PCR
machine essentially so and then then
sort of the nucleic nucleobases based
nucleotides esli at least as sort of
that starting point so so not an awful
lot actually PCR yeah but that but here
here I guess we're talking about things
that can scale to thousands over for
tens of thousands of human human doses
so yeah you probably need something
shooting container size without scale
consider you know a factory that makes
shipping containers all right we're
gonna finish up guys have any final
things mo I know you've got something to
say I'm seeing it in your face you know
outside outside of bioterrorism I'd say
you know just the social ramifications
of you know something I'm cognizant
of you know technology critics
accelerating rich-poor gap writings in
the future if it's only you know wealthy
people that have access to some of these
therapies and things like that or if we
start to be able to engineer the human
race but it's only wealthy people that
can do it
that completely creates this larger
chasm that what we're already you know
experiencing even in the United States
right if you look at the election and
some of the ramifications of that the
consequences of that and things that
were even happening before that and then
also just you know loss of privacy or
worry about - if you know you're leaving
your DNA everywhere and it's cheap
enough to be sequence with a handheld
device then anyone contract anywhere you
go it's already happening the digital
sphere now with being online and then
also just cameras computer vision being
ubiquitous but if it's also DNA you know
you start to really you know the end of
privacy could be real so there's some of
the outside of terrorism which is you
know I think always a concern but
relatively low risk at least now just
things about our day-to-day and social
interactions that could change alright
any thanks for having us and if you have
any questions you can hang out and ask
them to us but appreciate it everybody
for listening to a ramble about crazy
stuff
[Applause]
you